alors j'ai une spéciale dédicace pour
les trois batardeau remorque aimant
tomber dessus le sanglant mort le jo toi
aussi tu es mort tu as pu voici david
lopez qui vient de la nièvre et qui a
fait une vidéo en 2012 parce qu'il était
très remonté contre joe lopez un autre
lopez de pierre nous ferons le stock est
mort va le manger loi kaka deux morts on
vient d'apprendre des nouvelles insultes
dont on n'a jamais entendu parler des
insultes avec david lopez bonjour ce qui
termine par mort devient une insulte
callac de ces morts sans ces morts
fattar de ces morts piège trop fait de
la mort ce champignon à la semaine
prochaine c'était à prendre des insultes
avec david lopez lors david a voulu
faire participer sa femme à cette vidéo
c'est une sorte de collaboration
artistique voit la main dans la main
font ça ensemble c'est très beau mais
aujourd'hui j'ai d'abord ami david david
ne peut pas dire ferme ta gueule et tu
parles dans la même phrase d'une heure
le super eagle dealer le sens garde
rigole pas et d'ailleurs je dis plus
rien tu vois le son vers nagl david cd
roland je ne contrôle pas rarement il a
tenté une insulte je me suis mis à la
place de sa femme et ça m'a pas fait
plaisir morbide ta femme yeux des
passants ont lieu en mai 2012 il touche
à la fin du monde
vous allez payer vous inquiétez pas non
non non non non on est en 2015 toujours
pas de fin du monde je crois je crois un
fort à cons
confiante ça et maintenant la réponse de
jo et tout d'un coup ça monte d'un cran
appelle lopez go je voulais faire ça
arrive parce qu il y ait appel qui
venait avec moi
on remarquera le souci de mise en scène
pour impressionner un torse nu avec
d'autres mecs musclés alors ça ne marche
que si tu as le bon entourage
par exemple ça ne ça ne marche pas - fr
la vidéo ce qui ne tape est là qui dit
qu'il est on m'a dit que c'était
musculaire
voilà ça c'est du muscle salut ça c'est
plus le regarder faire des vidéos de ses
comptes en présence est facile en
maintenant je suis le regarde je suis là
clermont ferrand vient quand tu veux les
coups de poing les papes est à moitié
prix des vaches des coups de fusil alors
à ce moment là j'avoue j'avoue avoir un
petit peu peur pour ma vie en faisant
cette vidéo je devrai bien vivre encore
un peu lopez un bon je veux bien
apprendre les nouvelles insultes
ok par contre à prendre une toute
nouvelle langue non alors là je non non
je ne comprends pas important j'ai mis
des sous titres automatique ça ne marche
pas vous les mecs petits conseils de
youtube heures quand tu fais une vidéo
tu te retiens de ce gratte et les
couilles
mais même si ça gratte fort même si ça
tu n'en as pas qu'ici la commune volet
d'une chute à moi j'ai fait des millions
d'imagés d ela bref au métro un truc
d'une telle que je sais pas visiblement
ça démange mais moi j'ai envie de
gratter je ne sais pas pourquoi et je
termine la vidéo sur un trait de
modestie moi je suis pas arrivé à un
banquier comme ce soir
voilà je vais 75 kg et forcément
surprise pour un prime en personne
réponse de david gaud écoute moi bien
respectueux et je passe tous
j'étais prêt je t'éclate et moi je pêche
depuis donc ta femme en plus part du
marché
toi christian tu parles toi moi je t'ai
donné rendez vous jetez appelé faut
qu'on se bat tous les deux à ta tête tu
as même pas voulu faire 100 km vite ça
c'est normal je dois me faire démonter
la gueule 100 km à l'est 100 km autour
je vais peut-être trop pas accepté avoir
quand même ce que je fais demain j'adore
david parce que dans ces messages c'est
vraiment chanteur de métal car ta clique
de pda avec toi la petite chienne
moi je viens tout seul david un petit
peu menti un tout petit mensonge voilà
il indiqué tout seul bon il a fait une
autre vidéo après ça on attend les
voleurs mon david tu prends des mecs
chaud patate mais son bouillon qui
fusille comme ça c'est super pourquoi tu
comptes à partie le seul mec qu'on a
l'impression qu'ils se demandent ce
qu'il faut ici j'avais du mal à les
départager dit je préférais entre david
et joey c'est vrai que joe un argument
plutôt pas mal la famille lopez fait la
btk cld tiendront cordes tout la
mâchoire cassée et ne cortès un rappeur
qui est pote avec les lopez du 63 et la
légende raconte qui roulent en v 12 et
qu'il a l'humour de jamel debbouze
straka non non non non non tu fais un
clip musical tu ne te filme pas devant
un tag qui a une faute à chaque mot ils
sont douze mille dans le clip il ya
personne qui s'est dit il ya une faute à
chaque mot chat noir il ya une faute
c'est pas normal un petit conseil pour
enoch quand tu fais un clip que tu
prennes des mecs musclés mais un
acrobate dangereux non kaka qui avait
pas non plus tu es obligé de l'esquivé
pendant curable par le mec il infernal
démentant tout le monde est super
impressionné moi je suis pas
impressionné à temps elle a su des super
bons réflexes acquis puisqu'il tout
comme ça voilà c'est tout pour le clash
développer comme ça là au coup de poing
ma le projet le net open
pour moi c'est pas les gens alors oui il
ya une famille lopez qui n'a rien à voir
avec le clash ils ont rien moi si ce
n'est le nom
mais ils interviennent quand même je
suis particulièrement fan des mecs
derrière très passif
1 il ne bouge pas et un groupe bien sûr
quand ils entendent le mot clé dès
qu'ils entendent castagnettes c'est pas
les gens comme ça car j'ai un peu de
peine pour le pour le mec à droite qui
veut participer mais il
il ne laisse pas sa chance c'est
simplement la pop 15h41
et puis menace ou le fictionnaire en iut
volet moi moi pas de problème nous
allons nous trouvons trouver le mec à
gauche oui c'est tout ou rien 1 c'est
une sorte d' 1 2 3 soleil s'ils ne
bougent pas fait mes frères et de tous
ces partis
voilà c'est tout pour le clash des lopez
alors bien sûr c'est de l'humour allez
lopez laisser le jeu de vivre n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à ma chaîne
et comme disait l'autre à 6,36 à les
approches je raccroche pour faire une
imitation de squeeze et norman fin ça
croire que toutes les filles sont mises
d'accord trop mais norman tu es trop
moche ouais t'as trop raison
super